the big thing yesterday was that jesse
smollette who uh created a fake
hate crime against himself by hiring two
guys to put a noose around his neck and
there was a subway sandwich and it was a
whole thing and basically the media fell
for it hook line and sinker it proved
that we are a systemically racist city
uh country and everything else uh it
turns out that uh none of it happened
and he's going to jail so that's pretty
great uh here's video of him being
sentenced and his little outburst
i'm fashioning the following sentence
and here's your sentence
i'm sentencing you to 30 months felony
probation and the probation is going to
be to this court
you will pay restitution to the city of
chicago in the amount of 120 106 dollars
you are fined
twenty five thousand dollars which is
the maximum fine
and you will spend
the first 150 days of your sentence in
the cook county jail and that will start
today right here right now
no i would just like to say to your
honor that i am uh
i am not suicidal
that's what i was trying to say okay i'm
not suicidal okay i am not
suicidal i am innocent and i am not
suicidal
if i did this then it means that i stuck
my fist in the fears of black americans
in this country for over 400 years and
the fears of the lgbtq community your
honor i respect you and i respect the
jury but i did not do this and i am not
suicidal and if anything happens to me
when i go in there
i did not do it to myself and you must
all know that
i respect you your honor i respect your
decision
jail time
i am not suicidal okay
wow i mean what you've got right there
is a liar and a huckster and i'm pretty
sure he's telling everybody that he's
about to kill himself in jail because he
wants a further conspiracy theory or
something else i mean that's seriously
psychologically depressing and whatever
else uh before i jump to you guys there
was a gajillion
we roughly estimated that number
gajillion blue check politicians actors
etc etc when this originally happened
saying how this proves that america is
systemically racist and everything
defiant else caught this one from our
wickedly brilliant vice president
this is way back when when the first
thing broke jesse smilet is one of the
kindest most gentle human beings i know
i'm praying for his quick recovery this
was an attempted modern day lynching no
one should have to fear for their life
because of their sexuality or color of
their skin we must confront this hate of
course nancy pelosi also had one of
these and aoc had one of these and just
all the usual suspects and of course you
can see the hill headline below that he
got suspect
prosecuted for the 150 days in jail for
faking the hate crime um
ian i'll start with you on this a
certain amount of people are just
they're not going to accept what reality
is on this one huh
i mean once you've doubled down though
you might as well i'll keep doubling
down because that was his whole goal the
whole time what i really want to say
though is that 150 days is not that much
for the consequences of what he
was accusing someone of let's just say
there was a miracle and two white men
were walking around downtown chicago
sub-zero temperatures with maggie hats
on and they were arrested do you think
jesse smilet would have come out and
said no i made the whole thing up or do
you think they would be in jail right
now for decades like he could have
ruined real people's lives and 150 days
is really not that much of a slap on the
wrist in my mind i think it's it's
really appalling that you can play with
people's lives you can ruin people's
lives the risk reward here is just not
correct
yeah kyle what do you make of the
outburst at the end i mean first off
still saying that he didn't do it i mean
everyone knows that he did it this is
not this is not up for debate at this
point but then the really bizarre
suicide thing i mean just sort of going
for the ultimate victim play like he
wants he was a fake victim now going for
the ultimate victim plan obviously i
don't want the guy to kill himself but
you can sort of see where this thing
feels like it's going
is is he suicidal i mean he kind of left
some doubt in my mind well if this was
jesse's smallest edition audition to get
back on a network show i think he's
gonna have to take some correspondence
courses while he's in jail uh maybe get
a couple of nigerian guys to to coach
him on uh through it uh you know because
he's the only thing he was missing was
like a fans like oh i'm getting the
vapors or maybe the fred sanford oh look
out this is the big one
uh you know it was really
cringe-worthy and awkward and pathetic
and uh you know i think
it's kind of the you know colin
kaepernick syndrome and all of this
stuff you know
the more the more that they you know
clown themselves out in front of the
american public the stronger they get
because the woke left they eat it up so
much but at the end of the day i i just
think that you know whether it's pelosi
or biden or harris jumping onto this
it's it's not because his story is true
it's just that the narrative is the one
that they want to spread it's a useful
myth as sorel uh called it uh it's it's
something that furthers the democratic
party's cause and nobody who who pushes
useful myths uh is punished in the
culture or is punished uh punitively in
in our criminal system in america
anymore so i think it's a it's a sign
that really we're we're swimming in this
sort of uh
cultural marxist environment where
these radical leftists are rewarded no
matter how much they lie no matter how
much they defraud the american public uh
you know if they're grifters they can
get rich yeah i mean it's it's really
you know we we need to change the
culture if we're going to change the the
politics and the justice in this country
so
um i i think it's
you know something that that's very
important for us on the right to to
think about and you know daily wire i
saw you know doing stuff like that in
the entertainment field and everything
we need to do we need to do more of that
on the right because
uh
because because what jesse it is done to
this country is is like deliberate
vicious and uh
and it's really dangerous and it's
caused a lot of grievances and
and and it's really
um made the the legitimate grievances of
people who are affected by racism seem
uh you know it's diminished that yeah so
let's let's stick with that sarah i'll
give you the final word on this and then
we've got to jump um
in terms of the culture part of this
because i think i think we probably all
agree kyle is right that the we have to
win this culture war you know of course
politics is downstream from culture
andrew breitbart all of that um
is it starting to shift i mean we
started with the don't say gay thing and
it's like a lot of people are seeing the
nonsense for what it is a certain amount
of people will wake up and be like boy i
i really fell for that jesse smellet
hoax what else do you think we can do to
to shift the game
i mean i think that we need to continue
uh calling out all of this nonsense for
what it is continuing to draw attention
to the left's hypocrisy i think the the
barometer the real barometer that we
have coming up obviously is the midterms
uh and seeing what happens there uh you
know
despite any you know uh
attempts to
change the votes but uh i think that
that's all that we can do we can
continue fighting fire with fire i think
for so long conservatives were so uh
stuck with you know what i don't like
what's going on outside of my house but
i'm i work for a living i have my family
i keep to myself i just want government
out of my business and i'm just going to
stay within uh the confines of my own
bubble i think that we are seeing that
we cannot do that anymore we have to get
out we have to get involved we have to
get involved at local levels get
involved with your school board we have
to be calling out all of this hypocrisy
and nonsense every single day and
drilling it into these people because
they've been doing all of this for so
long they are professional uh you know
instigators they have infiltrated all of
these organizations and we have to be
able to uh to fight back and really get
active about calling these things out
because you know you may think that they
scream the loudest and the squeaky wheel
gets the grease but i don't think that
that's always the case so hopefully the
barometer of the midterms will end up
showing us that we are on the right
course or more so that the leftists are
on the wrong
one you